صحيح ان الحرب وضعت اوزارها بين الشمال
والجنوب في السودان لكن الصحيح ايضا ان
الحرب تفجرت بين رفاق سلاح الامس حروب
طاحنه بين جناحين متنافسين هم الرئيس
سلفاكير ونائبه رياك مشار ظاهرها سياسي
لكن باطنها قبلي رحيل مبكر لزعيم الانفصال
او الاستقلال جون جارانج افشل ربما نموذج
دوله كان يحلم به فتفجرت معه المتناقضات
صراع قبلي دامن يغذيه فساد سلطوي ومالي
طاحونته مليارات الدولارات من النفط
والغاز الضحيه هو المواطن الجنوبي الذي
حلم باستقلال او انفصال لكنه استيقظ فجاه
ليجده كابوسا يطارده ليلى ال نهار سنشاهد
القصه وسنناقش مع ضيفين هنا في الاستديو
اتيم سايمن الخبير في شؤون جنوب السودان
ومن الخرطوم المحلل السياسي السوداني
محجوب محمد صالح ننوه مشاهدينا الى اننا
شرعنا منذ ثلاثه ايام في تلقي مساهمتكم
عبر مختلف منصات التواصل الاجتماعي سنعرض
ما يرد منها خلال النقاش في حلقتنا هذه
امامكم الان على الشاشه ارقام للمشاركه
المرئيه اضافه الى الوسم الخاص بالحلقه
لكن ما رايكم الان ان نتابع قصه جنوب
السودان مع فراق الدم الفيلم الذي اعده
واخرجه زميل وجدي
[موسيقى]
كامل
k
عشت منذ صغري بالنك انا وامي واهلي كنا
نعيش كاسره كبيره بعد الحرب لا ادري اين
هم او
البقيه عندما هربنا هربنا الى الجيجر لقد
قتلوا اناسا كثيرين منهم صديقاتي واقاربي
اما الباقون فلا ندري
مكانهم اليوم الذكرى الثانيه لعيد
[موسيقى]
الاستقلال قبل نحو ثلاثه اعوام كانت ثمه
حياه واعده
بجوبا ننظر اليها من خلف الجبل فترى مدينه
تتاهب تنسم يوم ماطر
جديد ولكن كنت وانت تجوب شوارع جوب ليلا
او نهارا يتملكك شعور قوي بغياب الامن
[موسيقى]
والامان امن يبدو متماسكا ولكنه قد ينهار
امام اي انفلات حتى ولو كان مشاجره ص
صغيره بين
شخصين لا ادري لما اطلقوا النار علي
وسرقوا دراجه
[موسيقى]
البخاريه مشكله كبير توجد مشكله امنيه
كبيره هنا انت واذا ما اقمت بجوب هنا لفت
فانك وبلا شك ستسمع عن اشخاص يتم قتلهم
هنا وهناك ستسمع عن شخص تم قتله في وديلي
او في كاتول الحرب بين القبائل مستمره كما
هو في ولايتي جونجلي من حروب بين الدنكا
والنوير
[موسيقى]
ومورلي الصحفيون يواصلون
عملهم لنهم يجدون مضايقات كثيره من جهاز
الامن انا شخصيا تعرضت لست مرات
للاعتقال لقي كاتب صحفي بجنوب السودان
الاربعاء الماضي مسرعه بعد اسبوع من تلقيه
تهديدا بالقتل في حادثه تعتبر الاولى من
نوعها في الدوله الافريقيه حديثه
النشا
يوم 23 ناس جروا في الثال والعشرين هرب
الناس من
المدينه في الصباح وقع هجوم من
المعارضه واستولى عناصرها على قياده الجيش
الحكومي وكذلك على
يوم الخمس يوم الخميس بداوا يداهمون
البيوت واصبحوا يقتلون وهنالك جار لنا
قتلوه فقدت الكثير من اهلي في هذه الحرب
اشياء كثيره رايناها في هذه الحرب لقد
ذبحوا الاطفال واختطفوا
[موسيقى]
النساء
ان التحديات الاخرى تكمن في تعزيز وحدتنا
وبنائا الوطني عبر تطوير ثقافه نبذ العنف
والكراهيه بين
الاثنيات ان اولك باستهداف القتل المؤسس
على القبليه او الجنسيه يجب معاقبتهم
وتقديمهم الى
العداله ال 15م عشر من شهر ديسمبر عام
2013 تعلن اجهزه الاعلام العالميه خبر
اندلاع قتال بمقرات الحرس الرئاسي لدوله
جنوب
السودان
[موسيقى]
انه قتال محدود محدود للغايه يندلع في
الحرس
[موسيقى]
الرئاسي ظهور اعلامي للرئيس سلفاكير
ميارديت يتهم فيه نائبه السابق وخصمه
التاريخي اللدود رياك مشار بمحاوله فاشله
للقيام بانقلاب
عسكري ويثبت على انه زول مجرم حمشي
المحاكم عشان انه يستجيب على جرائمهم زول
نادي بالديمقراطيه ويجي يقول قال عمل
الانقلاب ما
ممكن رياك مشار يهرب عبر النهر الى مناطق
نفوذه القبلي ويرد نافيا قيامه بايه
محاوله كتلك وان الرئيس لم يجد سوى تلك
الروايه لجعله كبش فداء هو ورفاق له
بالحركه
الشعبيه الحرب
الان ساعات قليله ويعم القتال مناطق
مختلفه من العاصمه جوبا ويسمع دوي
[موسيقى]
الانفجارات جمهوريه جنوب السودان احدث
الدول المستقله بافريقيا والعالم تدخل
وبعد مضي 18 شهرا في حرب ضروس وايام
داميه الدوله الوليده في عين
العاصفه مشهد من التصفيه الدمويه القبليه
بين قبيله الدينكا
والنوير يبدا فيقع نتيجه ذلك مئات القتلى
والف الجرحى من
الطرفين مليونا مواطن مشرد من ضمنهم
730 الف شخص نزحوا الى البلدان
المجاوره ترتفع معدلات التضخم بينما تواجه
العائلات والافراد خطر الموت قتلا وجوعا
[موسيقى]
المقارع الحربيه والمواجهات الداميه
تتصاعد وتنتشر بسرعه البرق الى ولايات
اخرى من
[موسيقى]
البلاد
تحرق المدن ويشرد
السكان لم اكن اتوقع ان يحدث شيء
كهذا الجمعه الس 16س عش من
ديسمبر يقتل ما لا يقل عن
58 شخصا ويجرح اكثر من 100 في هجوم على
احدى قواعد الامم المتحده جوب العاصمه حيث
لج الاف
المدنيين العدد وبعد ايام قليله يصل الى
67 الف شخص ينحدرون من اثنيات
مختلفه ايام وتهاجم القوات العسكريه
الحكوميه بقوه تشكلت من
350 مسلحا قاعده الامم المتحده بم بور
بغرض قتل اكبر عدد ممكن من
اللاجئين كبار السن والعجز الذين تركناهم
خلفنا تركنا كل شيء خلفنا ولا توجد منظمات
هنا
[موسيقى]
لمساعدتنا القبعات الزرق تتهم كرد على
هجوم بور حكومه جوبا باستفزاز المهاجمين و
بايواء مناص
للمتمردين من اثنيه
النوير ان الهجوم الذي وقع على مقر الامم
المتحده يعتبر خرقا
جديا ليس صحيحا في اننا يمكن ان نكون
اعداء للامم المتحده هنالك افراد وبمساعده
قوانين الامم المتحده هم من قام باختلاق
تلك المشكلات ارحب بهذا القرار الذي يدعو
الى وقف فوري للاعمال القتاليه وفتح باب
الحوار كما يدعو الاطراف جميعا الى
التعاون مع بعثه الامم المتحده في جنوب
السودان جون كيري يحط رحاله بجوبا ويرسل
رساله شديده اللهجه يتهم فيها جميع
الاطراف بممارسه سياسه التطهير
العرقي هنالك اوضاع مضطربه بحيث ان
الاثباتات الداله تشير الى وجود تطهير
عرقي ممنهج بواسطه بعض
الاثنيه سمعت انهم قد ذبحوه لا ادري مكانه
حتى
الان انا مصدق باني حي عام واخر ينقضي
والحرب تحرق البشر والزرع والثقه بين بني
الجلده الواحده فكيف فسر الاضاض حقيقه
الحدث الخلاف بين الرئيس البكير وم دينكا
و
مشار من
نوير بينظر انه نوير يريد ان ياخذ سلطته
ان الصراع وكما بدا مبكرا يدل فقط على
قضيه الصراع على السلطه الصراع هو من اجل
الاستحواذ على السلطه داخل الحركه
الشعبيه بيد ان الحرب لم تبدا
[موسيقى]
بالرصاص
الخلافات العميقه داخل قياده الحركه
الشعبيه والتي يزيدها سوءا التوجهات
الدكتاتوريه لرئيس الحركه الشعبيه وتعطل
اجهزه الحزب من المستوى القومي الى المحلي
من شانها ان تخلق حاله من عدم الاستقرار
داخل الحزب وفي البلد التوقيع رياك مشار
نائب الرئيس وباق اموم الامين العام
للحركه
الشعبيه
2013 توجيه تهمه الفساد والاستيلاء على
المال العام لاثنين من القيادات التاريخيه
للحركه
الشعبيه الاثنين ال 2 من يونيو
2013 المجموعه الدوليه التي اسهمت
باستقلال الجنوب تخاطب الرئيس سلفاكير
ميارديت عبر رساله
ساخنه الفساد في صدر العديد من المشكلات
التي تواجه دوله جنوب السودان حتى اصبح
اسم بلدك مرادفا
للفساد فسادي دي موجوده لكن درجه الشفافيه
بتاعته في دوله الجنوب السودان حتى الناس
بنزور ققول تقول فسادكم قالنا فساد الفساد
ليس بالموضوع البسيط انه مشكله كبيره
الاموال التي تتم سرقتها هنا ليست
بالاموال البسيطه انها مليارات الدولارات
مليارات الكلام عن
الفساد مش كلام عام مش عمومي يعني في
اشكال معينه وهي فساد مربوط بناس معينين
نعم
بنقر بوجود
فساد
وعلنا الحرب على الفساد في بلد
و تقودوا
نخبه
قامت لاشاعه العدل في المجتمع لتنميه
المجتمع اي انفاق غير امين للثروه خيانه
وطنيه يوليو
2013 يقيل الرئيس سيلفاكير ميارديت نائبه
رياك مشار من منصبه كنائب للرئيس بعد ان
عبر الاخير عن رغبته في الترشح لانتخابات
رئاسه
الجمهوريه
جوبا الثامن من يوليو
2015 تتزكر الفتنه ويتعمق الخلاف بتمديد
برلمان جنوب السودان الفتره الرئاسيه
لسيلفا كير
[موسيقى]
ميارديت رياك ماشار المثخن بالخلافات
راعات التاريخيه في الحركه الشعبيه وخاصه
انشقاقه عن الحركه عام
191 يوجه نقده للقرار ويطالب
[موسيقى]
بالاطاحة انب الاحداث او الزمن اكدت انه
ليس هنالك انقلاب بالطبع وكما قلنا منذ
البدايه لم يكن هناك انقلاب عسكري
الانقلاب دائما ما يتم بواسطه عسكريين
بدعم من سلطه بعض السياسيين انهم يذهبون
ويحتلون الاماكن الاستراتيجيه ولكن وحتى
الان لم يتم اعتقال اي عسكريين قاموا بمثل
هذه
الافعال العالم على مرا من
الاحداث
منظمه الامم المتحده تشجو ومنظمه ايقاد
لدول شرق افريقيا تبذل مساعيها لاحداث
سلام بين
الفرقاء الامم المتحده وعلى لسان الامين
العام تصرح بان زعماء جنوب السودان خذلوا
شعبهم باعطائهم الاولويه لطموحاتهم
الشخصيه مجل الامن يهدد بوضع اي شخص يعمل
على تقويض الامن او عرقلته على قائمه
سوداء لكنه لم يفرض حتى الان حظرا للسفر
او يجمد اصول اي مسؤولين في البلد الذي
يمزقه
[موسيقى]
الصراع الرحيل
الحارق
[موسيقى]
الضرب وقت اصل في الكجر عندما وقع الضرب
بالجر كان باتجاه
الشارع هربت الى الشاطئ
هنالك اناس تمكنوا من الهرب
بالمراكب كنت اسرع باتجاه مركب ولكني لم
اتمكن من الوصول
اليه رقدت باتجاه شاطئ النيل بالاتجاه
الشمالي وكانت اناره السيارات قويه للاع
فوجدت سياره من نوع صغير تقل ثمانيه اشخاص
بدلا من
اربعه لم اجد
مكانا
داخل خلفيه
العربه انا كنت صغير ما بعرف حا لم اعرف
منذ صغري شيئا اسمه الحرب لم افقده بهذا
النحو ابي الان
افتقده تغتصب مئات النساء والفتيات في
منازلهن وبين
الاحراش وشبح المجاعه يهدد مليوني مواطن
جنوبي
بالامس القريب اتفقت النخب الجنوبيه على
قرار الاستقلال ليجد حوالي 6 ملايين مواطن
انفسهم بين ليله وضحاها راحلين الى
موطنهم واليوم يجد المواطنون الجنوبيون
انفسهم ضحيه لقتال محررم وثوار الذين
رهنوا على عسكره الدوله وتعبئه المدن
بالبارود ساضرب بدون حساب لو تمكنت من اخذ
هذا السلاح جيمس وانجا جاءنا وقال لنا
السلام قد اتى واستعمار الشماليين قد
[موسيقى]
انتهى ان نو
الكيه سربت كنتيجه لهذه الحرب لامر مذهل
لقد كانت حربا
مدمره يضغط المجتمع الدولي باتجاه
المصالحه الوطنيه وتعقد بتنزانيا واثيوبيا
العديد من جلسات التفاوض بين الطرفين
المتحاربين دون الوصول الى صلح يداوي
الجراح فريقي بجوبا قريبا سنرسل فرقا
جديده الى جبا لتنفيذ متطلبات الاتفاقيه
ليس من مجال غير تطبيق
الاتفاقيه على حافه الهاويه يتصارع
الطرفان حتى مثول اللحظه
الفارقه
لسنا سعيدين بهذه
الاتفاقيه لانها اتفاقيه سيئه بها الكثير
من التناقضات لا توجد اتفاقيه سيئه اذا
اوقفت
[موسيقى]
الحرب اخيرا يتم وقيع على اتفاقيه سلام
تعيد مشار الى منصب النائب الاول لرئيس
الجمهوريه بعد معاكسات عديده واجهتها رحله
عودته وانتظار دام
امده يلقي سلفاكير خطابا تاريخيا يعترف
فيه بان القياده كانت سببا للحرب
[موسيقى]
والدمار سؤال صعب وقاس يمثل
الان كيف يمكن للعهود ان تحفظ وكيف يمكن
للاتفاقات ان تحترم في غياب مخاطبه
المشكلات التي انتجت
الحرب ففي احتمال الارتداد والنكوص فان
الدوله ستصبح كما الفخ الذي نصبه محررون
لشعب دفع الثمن ثق في
قيادته الحقيقه هي ان هذا الاستقلال هو
نتيجه للتصويت على تقرير المصير وهذا يعني
ان كل المواطنين مشاركون في صناعه جنوب
السودان الان لدينا مجموعه صغيره لديها
الشعور بهذا الاستحقاق وتقوم باعمال
الفساد وتاخذ كل شيء هذا ليس بالامر
المستحسن لانه بالطبع ضد
العداله
هنالك مهددات
هيكليه المهددات
الهيكليه
هي التكوين
القبلي والتكوين القبلي يعني في حد ذاته
ما سبب
للصراع الذي يجعل
الصراع اشد خطوره هو الاستغلال السياسي
للفوارق
القبليه
[موسيقى]
ا
اذا نرحب بكم مجددا مشاهدينا نذكر باننا
نواصل تلقي ارائكم واسئلتكم بشان موضوع
حلقتنا هذه عبر حسابنا على تويتر وصفحتنا
على موقع فيسبوك مره اخرى نرحب ايضا بضيفي
الكريمين في الاستوديو السيد اتيم سايمون
الخبير في شؤون جنوب السودان ومن الخرطوم
المحلل السياسي السوداني محجوب محمد صالح
لعلنا نبدا من الخرطوم ونود ان نعرف معك
سيد محجوب بدايه باعتقادك ما الذي غذى هذه
النزعه الانفصاليه لدى الجنوبيين وهم
ابناء وطن واحد مع الشماليين في
السودان
نعم
نعم الجنوب منذ استقلال السودان كان
يطالب بوضع خاص في الدوله
السودانيه وصفه في البدايه بانه وضع
فدرالي ثم
تطورت مطالب الجنوبيين وظهر
تيار استقلالي يدعو
للانفصال وفي
النهايه الاتفاقيه التي وقعت في 2005
منحته هذا الحق حق ان يقرر الشعب
الجنوبي مصيره وحده للسودان او استقلال
سيد محجوب عفوا سيد محجوب حتى المشاهد
الكريم نضعه في في صوره الامور منذ
بدايتها ان كنت تسمعني الى اي مدى
باعتقادك السياسات الاستعماريه دعنا نعود
قليلا الى الجذور هي التي غذت هذه
الاختلافات وحرصت على ابرازها الاختلافات
الاثنيه العرقيه الدينيه وحتى اللغويه بين
ابناء الوطن
الواحد طبعا هي
القضيه جذوره ترجع الى الفتره
الاستعماريه و
حقيقه السودان مثل مثل كثير من
الدول
الافريقيه نشات كيانات السياسيه نتيجه
للهجمه
الاستعماريه على افريقيا في القرن
التاس وهذه الهجمه قسمت الافريقيا الى
كيانات سياسيه رسمت حدوده لمصلحه الدول
المستعمره وضمت الكيانات في داخله فوا
قبليه وثقافيه وعنصريه عديده ا ولذلك اغلب
الدول الافريقيه عانت عند الاستقلال من
صعوبات بناء الدوله القوميه ا
لانه كانت القبليه مسيطره والفوارق
القبليه كثيره والسودان كان واحد من الدول
التي عانت من هذا ربما كان
الفوارق العنصريه والثنيه فيه اكثر من
غيره لكن هو اشترك مع كثير من الدول
الافريقيه في هذه الظاهره والدليل على انه
الدوله القوميه في افريقيا بعد الاستقلال
واجهت مشكله هي انه منظمه الوحده
الافريقيه في وقت مبكر من الستينات قررت
ان ان يكون
للحدود الموروثه من الدوله الاستعماريه
قداسه بحيث نحافظ على تلك الحدود ونبني
الدوله القوميه
داخلها البلاد اللي عانت من هذه المشكله
هي اغلب البلاد الافريقيه وضحه تماما سيد
محجوب دعني اتحول دعني اتحول الى ضيفنا
الكريم هنا في الاستديو السيد اتيم سايمون
سيد اتيم هذه المط طالب كما يبدو انها
متجذرا الى امد بعيد هناك من يتحدث عن
مؤتمر جب سنه
1947 حينها ظهرت اولى المطالب ب فيدراليه
لكن السؤال هذه المطالب السياسيه التي قد
يختلف او ربما يتفق معها البعض متى تحولت
الى مواجهات عسكريه بين الاخوه في البدايه
انا اشكر قناه الجزيره ل اتاحتها هذه
الفرصه لمناقشه قضيه
ومساله مهمه في اطار العلاقات التاريخيه
التي غادت الى قيام دوله جديده في جنوب
السودان وكما اسلفت من خلال السؤال
انه متى تطورت هذه المطالب الى ان صارت
مواجهات عسكريه كما تعلمين انه السودان
كدوله استغل في العام
1956 ا وقبيل الاغ خلال دوله السودان
واعلان الاستقلال من داخل البرلمان كانت
هنالك مطالب نعم للمثقفين والساسه
الجنوبيين في اطار الحوارات الدائره
للاستقلال ان يكون هناك وضع دستوري خاص
لجنوب السودان في اطار الدوله الواحده هذه
المطالب شعر الجنوبيين بان هناك عدم جديه
وعدم رغبه لتحقيق مطلب الفيدراليه فاختار
او حدثت اولى تفجر الصراع في توريد
195 وه واحده قبل قبل الاستقلال اذا هذا
هذا يجعلنا نقود السؤال انه مع قيام اعلان
قيام الدوله السودانيه بدات هناك بوادر
مواجهات ومطالب متاصله وكانت مطلب واحد هو
الفيدراليه الى ان تطور عبر التاريخ وصل
لمرحله لكن قبل ذلك ولاده الحركات المسلحه
نود ان نعرف معك انانيا واحد انانيا اثنان
وصولا الى الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان
لماذا هذا التطور الذي كان يفترض بالفعل
ان ربما يتخذ مسارا سياسيا تصالحي مطالب
سياسيه مثل ما قلنا نختلف او نتفق معها ا
هذه المطالب وهذه القضيه السياسيه بين
الشمال والجنوب قامت في اطار حوارات مبكره
كما اسلفت القول منذ ايام الاستعمار ولكن
النخبه السياسيه في جنوب السودان لم
تستشعر جديه الاطراف المفاوضه من الجانب
السوداني بانها ملتزمه ب هذه القضيه لذلك
كانت هناك بدايات لعمل وكفاح مسلح قاده
الجنوبيين انفسهم سناتي تماما الى هذه
النقطه ونفصل فيها اكثر نود ان نقف قليلا
مع بعض المدونات التي وصلت البرنامج منها
هذه المدونه من الصحفي والمدون بدوله جنوب
السودان الهادي هواري قال في مدونته
المرئيه ان اطماع القاده الشماليين
واستغلالهم لثروات جنوب السودان دفع سكان
الجنوب لاستبعاد خيار الوحده لصالح
الانفصال نتابع
اطماع القاده الشماليين في الحزب الحاكم
الا وهو حزب المؤتمر الوطني زاد من فرصه
الانفصال لابناء جنوب السودان تعمل
المؤتمر الوطني مواقع اتفاقيه السلام
الشامل اي تنفيذها التي وقعت في سنه 2005
كانت لها الاثر الكبير لتغيير اعراء
الكثيرين من ابناء جنوب السودان من راي
الوحده ما شمال السودان الى راي الانفصال
وهذا ما حدث من خلال نتيجه الانفصال التي
جاءت بنسبه كبيره عند اعلانها
اذا مره اخرى نعود الى ضيفين الكريمين
تحديدا السيد محجوب من الخرطوم سمعت ما
ذكره ضيفنا هنا اليوم تذب معه الكثير من
التحليلات من وجهه النظر جنوبيه بانه لم
تكن هنالك جديه لدى الشماليين في ايه
احاديث سلميه عن مطالبهم التي يرونها
مشروعه بالانفصال وكان ذلك منذ البدايات
لماذا باعتقادك ما الذي ادى بالفعل لوصول
الامور الى حروب الجميع تذكر حرب توريد
كما اشار ضيفنا الكريم التي كانت قبل
الاستقلال لكن ايضا حتى في عاد حكومه
الانقاذ كانت هناك مواجهات داميه ذ ذهب
خلالها ضحايا كثر للاسف من
الطرفين التمرد في جنوب السودان بدا قبل
الاستقلال اها وحركه التمرد اللي قادتها
الفرقه
الاستوائيه في شرق الاستوائيه توريت حدث
في اغسطس 55 والاستقلال كان في يناير
وسبب هو مشروع السودن في السودان المشروع
اللي ادى الى احلال سودانيين محل
البريطانيين وغير السودانيين اللي كانوا
في الاداره
السودانيه ومن اصل 800 وظيفه تمت سود نتها
نال الجنوبيون ست وظائف وال التركيبه بتاع
القوات المسلحه في الجنوب كان الجنود في
الفرقه الاستوائيه من الجنوبيين وصف
الضباط من الجنوبيين لكن
الضباط من الشماليين والانجليز
والسودن جاءت بالسودانيين كضباط ودخل
انفجر التمرد فالتمر ارتبط بقضيه السودن
والتمرد السياسي ايضا ارتبط بقضيه السودن
لانه احزاب الجنوبيه احست انه
الاستقلال منح الوظائف العليا في الدوله
للشماليين ولم ينصف الجنوبيين ا كان هذا
مستوى الصراع في الوقت ذاك
انه السودن لم تعطي الجنوب نصيبه العادل
من السلطه ا واضح تماما سيد مح ث
تطورت الصفوه
الجنوبيه نعم وضح تماما ساعود اليك حتى
حتى يعني نفهم هذه الجزئيه لكن كسبا للوقت
يعني فقط اتحول لسيد اتيم هنا نود ان نفهم
الان بدايه جذور الاقتتال الداخلي بين
الجنوبيين انفسهم التي يرجعها البعض الى
حتى ما قبل الانفصال وقيام دوله جنوب
السودان هناك من يشير تحديدا الى للام اك
ورياك ماشار حينما جرى حديث وما سمي سلام
من الداخل مع حكومه الانقاذ بانها كانت
الامر الذي طبعا لم يكن يوافق عليه لا جون
جارانج ولا الرئيس الحالي سلفاكير ميارديت
والذي يقول كثيرون بانه كان ربما بذور هذا
الانشقاق والاقتتال الحاصل والذي نشهده
اليوم ما رايك ا يسهب او تسهب كثير من
التحليلات الى ان واقع الصراع اليوم في
جنوب السودان
هو قائم على خلافات داخليه داخل المجموعه
الحاكمه اللي هي الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير
السودان وهي مجموعه حركه ت
حروريه بدات من الثمانينيات و رفعت شعارات
محدده ولكن كانت هناك تيارات في داخل هذه
المجموعه وبدات ايضا بوادر انقسام في عام
91 وتطور الامور وعاد المجموعات المنقسمه
رياك
مشار لكن ما اصل هذا الاقتتال هل هل هو
قبلي لان هناك من يسوق لانه بانه صراع
قبلي بين الدينكا والنوير لكن هناك من
يقول ايضا بانه ربما هذه ادواته قبليه لكن
اصل الصراع هو سياسي هو صراع سياسي صراع
قائم على علاقات السلطه داخل قياده الحركه
الشعبيه ذات نفسها وتطور الى ان يكون
السراع حول قياده الحركه وقياده الدوله في
2013 عندما بدات نقاشات حاده في المكتب
السياسي للحركه الشعبيه حول تعديل الدستور
حول الصلاحيات الممنوحه للرئيس حول فرص
الترشح داخل الحركه لانه دستور الحركه
يعطيك الحق في انك تترشح لمنصب رئيس
الحركه ومن ذلك ترشحك الحركه لرئاسه
الجمهوريه وهذه واحده من القضايا الرئيسيه
التي دارت حول نقاشات حاده في المكتب
السياسي مما قاد الى بروس سيارات ثلاث
تيارات فيما بعد اصبحت هي مجموعه الحكومه
براس سلفاكير مجموعه رياك مشار المعارضه
المسلحه ومجموعه المعتقلين السابقين براسه
الامين العام للحزب الحاكم هذه المجموعات
كلها تعبر عن تيارات داخل هذه الحركه وهذه
المجموعات ايضا انقسمت فيما بينها ولانه
هناك قيام لمس كما يبدو على السلطه وعلى
المال ايضا ارجو ان تبقى معنا سيد اتيم
ساعود اليك نود ان نتوقف قليلا مع المدونه
والنشطه الحقوقيه اريك حسين التي تحدثت عن
العامل القبلي في صراعات الجنوبيين وتاثير
ير اقتتال على مستقبل الدوله
نتابع الا يرث الانفصال اي رسائل
سلبيه على العكس تماما الانفصال اذا كان
وفقا لمعايير محدده وفقا لاسس محدده فسوف
يؤدي الى تقدم الدوله والى
تحضرها الاقتتال الحالي في جنوب السودان
لا يعزه الى القبليه بقدر ما هو فساد
وثروه الوتير التي تسير بها الدوله في
الوقت الحالي سوف يؤدي بلا شك الى تدهور
الدوله والى دمارها في وقت من الاوقات
مره اخرى نعود الى ضيفنا الكريم سيد وجدي
نود ان نتحدث قليلا عن جون جارانج رحيل
وما سماها البعض بالرحيل المبكر لجون جارن
باعتقادك الى اي مدى اثر بالفعل في وضع
اسس هذه الدوله
الحديثه نعم مؤكد
انه وفاه الدكتور جون جرن في تلك اللحظه
التاريخيه كان له اثر بعيد ا لكن دعيني في
بدايه اؤكد انه
الصراع داخل الحركه الشعبيه تاريخه اقدم
من ازمه وفاه الدكتور جون جرنج لانه
الصراع
بقياده ريك مشار ولم اقول ضد بقيه قاده
الحركه بما فيهم سلفاكير بدا في سنه
1991 ا قبل 14 سنه من وفاه دكتور جون جرن
وقبل ما تتم اتفاقيه السلام وده كان
انقسام داخل الحركه ودعيني اذكر ايضا
انقسام اخر داخل الحركه ظهر في مؤتمر
رومبيك في 2004 في نوفمبر اخر نوفمبر وده
كان بين سلفاكير و مجموعه ما سمي باولاد
قرن او كان وقتها ضم
دنجور وباج
اموم
دينج ف الصراعات في داخل الحركه قديمه وفي
بعد وفاه جون
جرن يعني ذهب الشخص الذي كان يستطيع ان
يجمع القوى المختلفه وان يصل الى حلول
للمشاكل وضح
تماما يتفق عليها فكانت هذه كانت ازمه
حقيقيه وضح تماما اذا هي كانت ازمه حقيقيه
لكن دعنا نتوقف سيد محجوب وكذا ضيفنا
الكريم ومشاهدينا مع ما ذكرته اليوم
مفوضيه حقوق الانسان التابعه للامم
المتحده في جناب التي نشرت تقريرا جديدا
مفصلا عما شهدته دوله جنوب السودان من
وقائع انتهاك جسيم لحقوق الانسان هذا
التقرير في الواقع اكد ان تلك ال جرائم
تستمر بلا هواده ودون عقاب واضاف التقرير
ان القتال بجنوب السودان تضمن استهدافا
للمدنيين بشكل مباشر على اسس عرقيه وجاء
في التقرير ان
217 حاله اغتصاب واغتصاب جماعي تم
اقترافها في قتال شهر يوليو جنوب السودان
واكد التقرير في سياق متصل ان معظم حالات
العنف الجنسي ارتكبت من قبل عناصر الجيش
والشرطه والامن بجنوب السودان اعود اليك
سي سيد اتيم عندما نسمع هذه التقارير
للاسف الشديد وعن الحاله الماساويه التي
ال اليها جنوب السودان بعد كل تلك الامال
التي عقدها ابناؤه عندما تم الاستفتاء على
الانفصال بنسبه تفوق 98% نتساءل حقيقه ما
اسباب ذلك والى اي مدى ربما القائمون على
امر دوله جنوب السودان مسؤولون بالفعل على
هذا الوضع الماساوي امنيا لكن وضع اقتصادي
ايضا مزدي مع
مزري عفوا مع زياده معدلات التضخم وانهيار
لجنيه جنوب السودان امام الدولار ا كل هذه
عوامل مربوطه بالحرب وتداعياتها المستوى
الامني والسياسي والاقتصادي وهذا كله
يتحمل مسؤوليته القاده في جنوب السودان
وكما اسلفت بالذكر بان هذه الحرب هي جاءت
نتيجه لتلا متبادل كل طرف من الاطراف كانت
يؤكد بان هو لم يكن متورطا في حاله الفشل
في اداره الدوله منذ ما قبل الاستقلال اود
ان اعود فقط لو تكرمت الى جون جارانج
باعتقادك الى اي مدى بالفعل ما سماه
كثيرون بالرحيل المبكر للرجل وقد سمعت ما
ذكره ضيفنا ايضا الذي ربما قد تتفق معه في
هذه النقطه بان له كان له الاثر الكبير
على ما الت اليه الامور الان في جنوب
السودان الدكتور جونجر ا كما يسميه الكثير
هو لحظه فارغه في تاريخ السياسه السودانيه
وكان صاحب كاريزما وحضور سياسي كبير
استطاع ان يدير من خلاله تناقضات كبيره
داخل الحركه التي كانت تضم مجموعات كبيره
غير منسجمه وغير متجاوبه في العمل السياسي
وكانت لكل
مجموعه تصوراتها التي ظهرت في تجليات
تاريخيه عبر مراحل مختلفه من انقسامات
وانشقاقات وتباين في المواقف لكن استطاع
ان يدير هذا هذه الحركه الى ان وقع اتفاق
سلام على مستوى السودان وكان تاثير غيابه
واضح جدا في انه ما تراه من مشروع ورؤيه
لم تجد التنفيذ الامثل وانما انحازت كل
مجموعه بعد ذلك الى انها تطبق روؤيه جونجر
لكن بطريقتها الخاص ماذا عن افاق المستقبل
باعتقادك سيد اتيم هل كان نود يعني ان
نطرح سؤال صريحا وتجيب عنه بكل صراحه هل
كان جنوب السودان جاهزا بالفعل هل كانت
اللحظه مواتيه ل اعلان هذا الانفصال عن
الشمال ا في البدايه جنوب السودان ا دوله
جاءت عبر رغبه شعبيه لمواطنيه عبر التص
تفي الرغبه الشعبيه عندما نرى النتائج
الرغبه الشعبيه لا لا لا لا لا يتم قياسها
على مستوى النتائج الرغبه الشعبيه انه شعب
جنوب السودان كان يتق لحريته ولكن فشل
غدته في اداره نموذج دوله متنوعه ومتعدده
زاخره بالموارد وامامها فرص كبيره في ان
تدير نفسها وتخرج بنموذج يحتذي به الاقليم
والعالم ويكون لديه اسهام في الاستقرار
والسلم الدولي والانسان يعني سيد اتيم
ارجو ان تبقى معنا نود ان نتوقف مع المدون
والناشط السياسي اندريا ماج مبيور عفوا
الذي تطرق لما سماه ندم الجنوبيين بشان
الانفصال عن السودان القديم من عدمه نتابع
وجهه
نظره شعب جنوب السودان ليس نادم على
الانفصال من السودان صحيح قامت حرب والحرب
شيء غير جيد الحرب مدمر ومكلف ولكن
السودان الذي استقل منه الجنوب ايضا يعاني
الحروبات الوضع في السودان لا يختلف كثيرا
عن ان الوضع في الجنوب هناك حروبات في
دارفور هناك حروبات في منطقه جبال النوبه
هناك حروبات في الانقسنا فهذا لا يجعل
السودان افضل حالا عن الجنوب
فليس هناك من هو نادم على الانفصال انا
السودان سيد محجوب اذا الجنوبيون وفق نظر
المدون التي كنا نتابعها غير نادمين على
الانفصال ضيفنا يقول هنا بانها كان نتيجه
لرغبه شعبيه بغض النظر عن النتائج التي
التت اليها وفشل القاده السياسيين
الحاليين لكن باعتقادك هذا الكابوس للاسف
الذي يعيشه يعيشه الجنوبيون والذي كان
حلما في يوم من الا ايام الى اي مدى يرسل
ربما برسائل سلبيه عن اي رغبه لانفصال او
تقسيم موجوده في اماكن عديده من
العالم انا
احترم حق الجنوبيين في ان يحصلوا على
حريتهم وان
يتوق لقيام
دوله مستقله ينتمون اليها لكن بنفس القدر
كنت اتوقع من القيادات السياسيه التي ساعت
لهذا
ان تدرك انه عليها اعاده
بناء الثقافه الشعبيه اللي كانت سائده في
الجنوب وهي ثقافه قائمه على التمرد على
السلطه وكان واضح انه اذا استقل الجنوب
فان عددا كبيرا من
القيادات القبليه ستستقل هذه الفوارغ
القبليه وتستثمر لمصلحه
شخصيه ونتذكر انه عندما منحت اتفاقيه ادي
سببه سنه
1972 الجنوب حكما ذاتيا حصلت سبع تمردات
اثناء حكم الجنوبيين لانفسهم عن طريق
جوزيف لاجو او ابي الير وفي كل الحالات
محجوب ولذلك العمليه في في
ابعاده كانت تقتضي ان يعمل تعمل القيادات
اشكرك جز على
اعاده يعني هيكله الدوله للاسف وقتنا
انتهى تماما اشكرك جزيل الشكر السيد محجوب
محمد صالح المحلل السياسي السوداني ضيفنا
من الخرطوم كما نشكر جزيل الشكر ضيفنا هنا
في الاستوديو السيد اتيم سايمن الخبير في
شؤون جنوب السودان لم يفرح للاسف سكان
دوله جنوب السودان طويلا بالانفصال فقد
خيم الاقتتال بين رفاق الخندق الواحد
واحكمت المصالح السياسيه والقبليه قبضتها
على جهود بناء الدوله الوليده وحولت احلام
الامن والرفاه بفضل الثروات النفطيه
والمعدنيه الواعده الى كابوس اثقل
المدنيين بالانتهاك الفظيع لحقوقهم
الانسانيه دوله تنتظر ان تحل بربوع روح
السلام وسلطه القانون وان تفرض العداله
تفرض العداله عقوبتها على المجرمين مهما
كانت مواقعهم السياسيه والامنيه وبغض
النظر عن مشاربهم القبليه ختام حلقتنا
نلتقيكم باذن الله في لقاء جديد مع بقيه
لقصه اخرى الاثنين القادم بحول الله
السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]
ه